moi j'étais très demandeur mais je n'ai
pas eu le temps de mettre en œuvre mais
c'est quelque part ça dépend du
ministère de la Culture une réflexion
globale avec les bâtiments de France
parce que effectivement sur ce le
patrimoine dont vous me parlez on arrive
à une difficulté c'est qu'on peut pas
saccager au nom de cette obligation
notre patrimoine qui soit particulier ou
que ça soit les bâtiments publics c'est
vrai que si on vous préconise une
isolation par l'extérieur d'une maison à
colombages pour me prendre que cet
exemple là c'est un peu un saccage donc
je pense qu'il faut là il y avait la
réflexion n'était pas aboutie mais elle
méritait d'être lancé parce que ça
concerne une partie de évidemment du
bâti en France mais là il fallait
effectivement essayer de voir s'il y
avait des alternatives pour ça tout à
l'heure je me suis permis de parler des
matériaux biosourcés parce que je pense
que là franchement économiquement
techniquement il y a une partie de la
solution voilà donc il fallait
probablement avoir une certaine
souplesse et c'est ça aussi
dans la progressivité c'est qu'il
identifié ce que je disais tout à
l'heure il y a des choses où c'est
possible et il y a des choses ou
d'évidence il y a pas besoin d'être
grand sorciers pour dire ben là c'est
très sympa mais voilà donc il fallait
aussi peut-être faire travailler un
certain nombre d'acteurs pour voir les
alternatives qui étaient qui étaient
proposées c'est clair que c'est vrai
aussi sur le les énergies renouvelables
bon ben on n'a pas envie de mettre une
éolienne sur Notre-Dame ou un panneau
solaire sur le fort de je ne sais pas
voilà donc après dans dans cette
mutation là évidemment il faut avoir un
petit peu de
pardon de dire mais un peu
d'intelligence pour ne pas sacrifier une
cause pour pour l'autre mais nous
n'avons pas eu le temps moi j'étais très
preneur de et notamment de travailler
avec les architectes parce que
ces sujets là pour beaucoup
d'architectes sont des sujets qui leur
sont totalement étrangers il fallait pas
abandonner la beauté des choses pour
l'efficacité il me semble pas quelque
chose de forcément qu'il ne soit pas
solutionnable